Interestingly, we're not going to talk about a version of the prototypal pattern
that does not involve shared methods.
When we were talking about decorators and when we were talking about
the functional class pattern, we examined the technique of using shared methods
or using methods that were defined in line in the body of the constructor.
But the prototypal pattern really does not lend itself well
to the same examination.
Why do you think that might be?
As I see it, function sharing via a prototype delegation is the very goal of
the prototypal pattern.
If methods were defined inside the constructor there really wouldn't be
any reason to delegate the instances to any prototype at all.
And that's it for prototypal classes.
With all of this background information behind us it's going to be very easy to
understand the pseudoclassical pattern.